[Musique]
je suis Franck Monier historien du droit
et doyen de la Faculté de Droit et
Sciences Politiques de
Versailles la nuit du droit c'est une
manifestation qui est organisée tous les
4 octobres le 4 octobre étant la date
anniversaire de la promulgation de la
Constitution de la 5e République et la
première édition de la Nuit du droit a
été organisée à l'initiative du
président du Conseil constitutionnel
Laurent Fabius il s'agissait de célébrer
les 60 de notre
Constitution l'objectif de la nuit du
droit est d'ouvrir les lieux de droit à
la société cela nous permet d'aborder
des thématiques en lien avec l'actualité
en lien également avec le quotidien et
les lieux de vie des administrés tout ça
avec comme objectif final comme dessin
de rendre accessible le droit de
démystifier le droit et également
d'améliorer la connaissance des métiers
du
droit il est important de de faire
connaître le le droit aux citoyens aux
administrés de façon à non seulement
améliorer la connaissance du droit mais
également à pousser les administrés à
faire valoir leurs droits beaucoup plus
facilement avec moins
d'appréhension